Please welcome Aurora!
Aurora, you have recorded your first album ...
And on that album, there are songs that ...
... you wrote ten years ago.
You were nine years old then.
Yes.
When you listen to these songs, can you hear a difference in how you wrote when you were nine and how you write now?
Yes, there's probably a little bit of a difference there.
The strange thing is that I wrote «darker» material when I was younger.
I'm a little more ...
... positive in the way I write now, than I was before.
And I think I just ...
Or, I think that ...
It's usually the other way around, that you see all the nice things when you're little, and then you grow up and realise how bad everything is ...
... behind the facade, sometimes.
But it was the other way around with me. I was quite observant. I enjoyed observing things ...
... and people and the world around me.
And I was very sensitive.
When I was little.
So things really affected me.
Do people feel more as children than as adults?
I think ...
I think you have the same amount of feelings as a child and as an adult.
But maybe you ...
You use the brain more when you grow up ...
... and follow your heart a little less. But I think that you ...
Maybe you only listen to your heart when you're a child.
What are your thoughts?
I agree. As a child ...
... you live in such a limited world that everything becomes so intensive.
And I think it was most evident at 14-15 years old, maybe ...
... because then you had this rush of hormones that caused you to fall in love ...
But at 19, you're quite in control.
And I think at that age, you don't allow yourself to feel as much, I think.
When you are a part of, as you now are, a music business ...
And you're in the big league, so to say ...
... there's a huge circus surrounding you.
Is it hard to remain the person you are?
Uhm, yes.
It is, really.
I think it is most of the time.
I'm sort of ... I've always known very well who I am as a person.
And what I stand for. And what I want.
But ...
All of a sudden, I had to find out ...
... what I had to be as an artist. And image, and music, and music videos and ...
And these days I've got a quite big team around me ...
And I'm quite small.
But I ...
I try to speak louder and louder ...
... with each day that passes, I think that's important.
You quit school.
To do this full-time.
Do you miss hanging out with people your own age and just ...
... be with them.
I was ...
I've never been very good a being a young person.
I was very good a being a child.
I think I skipped the youth phase.
I'm still part child and part adult.
But it has something to do with ... When you're as sensitive as I was ...
I was very easily affected by other people's energies and moods.
And what happens ... When you're with young people ...
... like you said, around the age of 14, everyone ...
Everyone has ...
Or, most young people, at least, have a little bit of chaos within themselves.
And you can feel the small storms that are in everyone.
And that's why it's quite nice to be with ...
... people who have let the storm calm down a little.
At least that's what I think. So I think I fit well with ...
... older people.
One of the really big artists in the world today is Katy Perry.
And she is a fan of yours.
And a lot happened in your career when she ...
... wrote that on Twitter.
You suddenly became a very international person.
You've later met her, right? She asked to meet you?
Yes, she came to one of our concerts last year, in L.A..
She was very nice!
I was very nice to see, she came ...
... as just ...
Katy.
I don't know her real name, it might just be Katy?
... Perry?
Yes?
But she was just there as herself.
No ...
... make-up, and no dress and ...
... no wig or stuff like that. She was just very ...
It was really nice to see ...
... her so real.
She was very down-to-earth. She greeted everyone in the band.
And she was just very kind, really.
She seemed very genuinely interested in music.
And she is just a person who ...
... loves music.
Did you think that you would want her life?
No.
It was very nice meeting her, but it was also a little sad.
Because you ...
I could sense that she was ...
... a little stressed about being there.
If anyone found out, everyone in ...
... L.A. would start screaming.
You ...
You could sense that worry.
She has lost a freedom that ...
... you should have, as a person.
To be able to just walk around, being a person.
Without being anything else.
Because you instantly become so much more, for everyone else.
That's a very strange and unnatural thing, really.
Aurora, thank you so much for being here!